Hi, and welcome to the Neil
Ashton Podcast.
In each episode, we explain
some of the fascinating ways
that science and engineering are
changing the world around us.
We talk to leading engineers
from elite level sports like
cycling and Formula One to some
of the world's top academics to
understand how fluid dynamics,
machine learning and supercomputing
are bringing in a new era of discovery.
We also hear some of their life
stories, their career advice,
the lessons they've learned on
the way that I hope will be
helpful to you too.
So sit back and enjoy this
episode.
Hi, and welcome back to the Neil
Ashton Podcast.
So today's guest is Joris Poort,
who is the CEO and founder of
Rescale.
He's somebody who I wanted to
talk to for a while as part of
the opportunity to speak to
people who have had that bold
vision to, to create a start up,
to create a new company.
And I thought it was really
interesting to try and learn
from these people, you know,
what motivated them to do in the
1st place, what some of the
lessons they've learnt in doing
that.
And it's particularly relevant,
I guess, for the themes of of
this podcast.
Rescale is, is used by actually
a lot of companies these days,
you know, if they want to
integrate more like high
performance computing and and
more recently more applied AI,
you know, they've got hundreds
of customers in this space,
enterprise customers.
So it's kind of interesting to
speak to somebody who looks
after that company and they have
a good sense of what's coming
next.
It's been a topic also this
podcast is looking at, you know,
what's the future of AI and we
we ended up talking for quite
some time about the potential of
agentic AI.
This is something that, you
know, myself and Joris turns out
are quite aligned on in this
could be quite transformative.
You know, we previously mainly
spoken about AI surrogates and
we we also do talk about that.
But I think the yeah, the the
agentic AI and the potential
this has for engineering was a
really interesting discussion
that comes probably in the
second-half of of the chat.
So it definitely tune in if you
want to hear some interesting
thoughts on that, given my
background, having worked at AWS
before and therefore being
immersed in the cloud computing
space, I always find that
interesting as well.
And how that has evolved.
You know, Rescale was created
like 2011, Oh, quite a long time
before, I guess ways today where
cloud is more mainstream and and
accepted, you know, and
Rescale's had some pretty
impressive founders, sorry, fund
funding from companies like
people like Sam Altman and Jeff Bezos,
Paul Graham.
So talk a bit about that with
the, you know, Y Combinator,
NVIDIA, Microsoft.
So, you know, it's, it's
impressive feat for someone to
create a company that's had
hundreds of millions of dollars
in funding.
And so I hope that you learn a
lot from some of his advice for
for maybe one of you who is
thinking about creating a, a
start up yourself.
I always talk about doing this
and I'm probably just too risk-averse to do it.
So, but don't listen to me,
listen to Joris and hopefully
you get some, some, some insights.
So this was a wide-ranging
discussion.
You know, we probably could have
taken it even deeper or in other
areas, but at an hour and a
half, I thought he was already
taking a lot of his time.
But yeah, I certainly learnt a
lot from this discussion and
have a renewed and even more
sense of, you know, appreciation
for what people like him do and
push the boundaries and try and
create new companies and ideas.
So hopefully it's an inspiration
for you listening as well.
So sit back and enjoy this
episode with Joris Poort.
Thank you for for coming and
doing this.
You're actually on the quite
high up the list of people I
wanted to speak coming I guess
from a cloud provider background
before sort of seeing cloud.
I think I joined AWS in
2020 and thinking, oh, this is
quite novel, this is quite new.
And then looking back and
realized that Rescale was part
of the Y Combinator in 2011.
So back then, HPC in the cloud
must have been even more
radical, even more sort of crazy
ideas.
So maybe it's a starting point.
I'd be interested to know like
what was your pitch for that
start up for for Rescale?
Yeah, absolutely.
So first of all, thanks for
thanks for having me on.
I think this is, you know a nice
opportunity to to take some time
and chat about the background.
I think for HPC in the cloud,
certainly when we started in
2011, it was a very new concept.
I will be honest, when we
founded the company, we thought
we were late to market because
cloud computing had already
started.
You had big data.
And it seemed pretty obvious to
me that there would be like a
sort of a big compute company.
And I actually looked for a
company to join myself to say,
hey, who who's doing this,
solving this problem, right?
And I had personally sort of
experienced this problem before.
So it seemed like we were late
to market.
Looking back now, we're quite
early to market, right?
So at that time there was
definitely 0% HPC happening in
cloud.
But it's, you know, it's been a
fun journey and things have, you
know, changed over time.
It was a tough process to get
people excited about actually,
you know, investing in this and,
and sort of joining the team to
pursue this.
But you know, like most good
start-ups, you can start with a
a great idea and and and lots of
effort and eventually you know
you can make it.
Yeah.
So maybe taking a step before
that, where had you been before?
What gave you that original
motivational idea even to
overcome these problems and and
create a start up, right.
That's still a a leap of faith
to leave a company to a start
up.
Yeah, absolutely.
I think for for me, my
background is quite technical.
So I'd studied, I grew up doing
a lot of computer science.
I'd studied applied math,
mechanical engineering,
aeronautics, astronautics.
I was sort of part of did a lot
of work in the field of multi-
disciplinary optimisation.
I know you come from a strong
CFD background, right.
So by the professor I studied
under actually was an aeroelasticity expert who was a
disciple of Lucien Schmit from
the sort of structure of the
first person to kind of do
structural optimization.
So I had sort of a background
there.
And then I, I spent some time
working at Boeing applying a lot
of these different kind of
tools.
So a lot of software, a lot of
math, a lot of different kind of
physics calculations for the 787
Dreamliner program.
And the, the big challenge we
had there was trying to solve,
it's the first kind of fully
carbon fiber airplane and the
wing optimization, wing being
kind of the most important part
of an airplane.
A lot of big technical
challenges are the main
difference being since it's
carbon fiber, many more
variables.
And how do you sort of optimize
this design?
And so I had a background there
kind of using different
techniques in in sort of
parameters trying to optimize
what it would be the lightest
weight wing design for the best
performance.
Long story short, took us many
years, but eventually we got
there and that's the wing if
you've ever flown on 787, that's
the that's the wing that's on
there.
So it's a very efficient
airplane, right.
But in order to do that and get
to that answer, we we really
have to leverage a lot of
different computing
capabilities.
And this was more than 20 years
ago.
So there was no cloud computing
yet.
So it was really much more about
how do we scale sort of a
distributed systems problem from
a software perspective inside of
Boeing with, you know, different
resources from different
business units that we would
sort of over the weekend be able
to kind of gather a bunch of
compute capacity service
together from different teams
and, and solve some of these
larger scale problems.
And eventually that that really
got me into HPC because it was
like in academia, I actually
studied more how do you solve
these equations more
efficiently, right.
So trying to combine aero-
elasticity, try to kind of
combine mechanical engineering
physics with, with fluid
dynamics and, and things like
that.
And with the ultimate goal of
just, you know, more efficiently
calculating all these different
complex multiphysics responses.
And at Boeing, we were
implementing with this sort of
multiphysics problem, but in a
very different way than how
academics kind of looked at the
problem.
It was much more about the,
let's throw some more compute at
this problem and like where are
the real bottlenecks and like
sort of how do you scale this?
And from my own experience, I
really enjoyed the ability to
kind of gather a lot of these
compute resources and just solve
interesting problems faster.
So that got me into this whole
sort of category of HPC. I.
Think one kind of insight as
well was like, you know, if you
look at kind of the people who
were the best aerodynamicists
at Boeing, for example, or the
best at some of these like large
physics computational problems,
they became the really good at
running HPC, right, Basically in
practice, right.
Like these are people at in
industry sort of working on
this.
And I, I, I think I sort of had
a background because of the
software and the math to be able
to solve those kinds of
problems.
But it's a really like a sort of
untapped potential to be able to
kind of unlock, you know, the,
the possibility of, of
leveraging really large scale
compute for many different
problems.
And so that sort of.
Led to hey.
This is an area I'm like pretty
passionate about.
I also tried some other things.
I was a management consultant
for some period of time, short
period of time, yeah.
And so like I, I went to
Business School.
So as I looked at it, I saw a
pretty broad set of different
things you could do.
But the thing that kept pulling
me back was I, I did really
think there was like a really
interesting problem and and
really impactful problem if we
could solve this sort of large
scale physics calculations for
like engineers and scientists
that really push the sort of
boundaries forward, not only in
a place like Boeing, but also in
many other industries, right, in
automotive and in life sciences,
semiconductor.
And so that seemed like a a
worthwhile sort of mission to
pursue.
But I'm, I'm kind of intrigued
the practicals of doing it
because I often feel that a lot
of engineers and maybe it's
changed now, haven't got the
mindset to create a start up
that, you know, they, they think
a little bit more linearly, you
know, OK, I'm going to do
engineering and make something
better.
Was it going to Business School
or going to McKinsey that gave
you a bit more confidence and
awareness to go and do a start
up?
Yeah, I think, well, there's,
there's many different things.
I I think ultimately for like
the best founders, they have
like a few traits that are
pretty common that together are
very uncommon, right.
So like it's see if I can sort
of recall, I think Marc
Andreessen sort of shared what
his perspective on this is,
which are like, like, I think a
pretty good viewpoint.
So what is you have to be very
open and curious, right?
So you have to be kind of
willing to learn many different
things.
And so that's probably also
pretty common with like people
in academia, things like that.
You also have to.
Be be pretty.
Willing to stick with something
and work through a lot of
challenges for a long period of
time.
And then there's this element of
like he calls it
disagreeableness, but it's like
you sort of have to be stubborn enough, right to be able it's
it's you know, starting a
company is not the most like
rational thing to do, right?
Like no matter kind of which
field you're in, it's, it's,
it's really hard, right?
And so it's like people do it
because they kind of have to,
not the people who just do it
because they want to.
It's, it's often for maybe not
the, the sort of ideal reasons,
right?
But you'd be sure to have these
different traits, you need a lot
of like, I think it's, it's
pretty risky.
And so like, and a lot of
people, you know, will tell you
to do something different or why
it's not going to work or why
everybody's already thought of
this idea from the founders.
I know.
I think it's just like, yeah,
it's, it's a combination of
these, all these different
traits, right?
And, and everyone is sort of
unique, also uniquely flawed,
probably in many ways.
I certainly AM, but but it is
hard to find.
I would say like and out of all
these capabilities, you have to
be really smart of course and
things like that.
But like the probably the one in
least supply is, is I think the
courage, right?
It's like sort of the
willingness to kind of jump in
and do it.
There are times though, when
entrepreneurship is much more
popular, right?
Like so when certain companies
are taking off and there's a lot
of funding and things look a
little like a little easier, you
get a lot of people jumping into
the game.
But most big companies are
really successful ones are built
over a very long period of time,
right?
And there's lots of ups and
downs.
Even if you look at the absolute
most successful companies, there
are really challenging periods.
And I think I think you have to
be willing to enable to kind of
work through those, those
difficult times, right.
And yeah, it's maybe something
from Jensen, I think I shared
before where it's like, you
know, like it, it's really the
challenges that that form the
character that allow you to to
become like one of these kind of
leaders of these companies.
It's probably not just, yeah,
just being smart or something
like that.
Yeah, what, what practically
though were the steps?
I'm always kind of intrigued.
So the beginning, you have an
idea.
How did that form?
Did you have an idea?
And then you, you know, you go
around to the various VCs to
get to get funding.
You had just a tiny idea.
And then it evolved like what?
How did this thing come to be,
essentially?
Yeah, there's a good book
written on this from by Peter
Thiel 0 to one, right?
It's like like how do you start
something from nothing?
I think the how how it
tactically works, right?
It's it's for me, it was about
sort of came to the conclusion
you asked about this as well.
Like what does Business School
really teach you?
I mean, I think the biggest
lesson from Business School is
maybe, you know, all these, at
least the one I went to, all
these different CEOs come
through, right?
And they give these talks.
These are all very impressive
people.
But I think the one thing once
you've seen enough of them,
right, you do all these case
studies and you learn all these
things.
It does give you the feeling
that at least for me, you know,
sort of you can really do
anything, right?
Like you hear these kind of
stories, the same thing if you
listen to like sort of founder
stories.
And I think you could kind of do
anything you set your mind to
do, right?
And it's in some ways one of the
best insurance policies, right?
Because like, look, you get this
Business School degree, you
know, you can go get a job
somewhere.
Like I had sort of, you know,
done this internship at
McKinsey.
I could go back there, right?
And that gives you, you know,
maybe sort of a floor of like,
OK, now I can take a lot more
risk right now.
This was a time I had to, I had,
I did not have a spouse that
didn't have kids.
I, I was actually at sort of a
point in time, I think where I
was able to take the most risk,
right?
And so I think that's sort of
sets a good foundation to jump
into to do it.
I would recommend, right?
Like you do have to kind of burn
the boats, right?
Like, so you can't be comparing
yourself to your peers who are
going to go work in finance or
whatever and make a bunch of
money or go work in academia and
publish the most papers and the
do most innovative kind of
thinking.
I have a lot of peers like that.
And I think you have to be kind
of get yourself to the point
where like you, you really do
want to start this company kind
of no matter what, right?
And then you kind of have to
like most founders describe it
as like, I would say that you
kind of have to right, Like you
just don't see any other way.
And that's kind of the how I saw
it.
It was not to just for the
purpose of starting company.
It was like.
To make the impact.
That I thought would be possible
like that I could make myself
right and I saw kind of was
possible at Boeing and then it's
like OK there's many other
industries there's many other
engineers and scientists who are
all like bottleneck by compute
basically right and then there's
this thing called cloud
computing and like everybody's
access to these and it seemed
again I felt I was late right
and so it seemed pretty obvious
to get to go pursue that the.
The tactical steps would be I
decided to just move to Silicon
Valley.
So like, I came out Silicon
Valley and I knew nothing right
about.
Silicon Valley, really like I'd,
you know, like read some books,
listened to some podcasts,
probably weren't really, I don't
even know.
What they were.
Called podcasts at that time,
but the you know, Stanford had
this like I think they still do
this entrepreneurial thought
leaders program.
And so I remember just listening
to these people come in and this
is a different generation.
So you talk about like, you
know, I was listening to this
stuff like like, like way back
in the day, right?
Like sort of 20, probably 2010 maybe earlier to yeah,
probably earlier.
But they give you some
inspiration and sort of a road
map of of like, you know, how
you can start a company.
There is something special about
Silicon Valley.
So you have this very high
concentration of founders, you
know, engineers who want to
build companies as sort of
builders, investors.
You have sort of a cultural
appetite for risk, right?
Like it's a, it's a very special
place.
And I do think if it's like my
mentality is a little bit like,
you know, if you're going to, if
you're going to go do something
like this, you might as well,
you know, try to sort of play in
the NBA, so to speak, right?
Like so many places you can
start a company, but I think to
give yourself the best chances
of success, it seems like moving
to Silicon Valley would be a a
good move, right?
But I literally moved out
without really, I had no family
or you know, I had some
classmates that also moved to
the Bay Area.
But I did not have any like like
sort of real good reason to be
there other than to kind of try
to start a company.
And I just started working at
writing code.
So I just started building the
product in parallel.
It was like, you know, trying to
see, hey, you know, can we raise
some money, etcetera.
But it was just by myself and
just writing some code.
That's really how it started,
right?
And I think you mentioned
earlier like sort of eventually
led to Y Combinator, which is
one of the incubators.
So that that can really help a
lot, right?
Because they that can give you a
pretty quick start and a very
fast network of other founders
and great mentors that I can get
you off the ground.
It's a little bit different than
today.
This is back in 2011, right?
So at that time you got to
remember it was like social,
local, mobile or all the hot
trends, right?
And so like sort of working on,
you know, a, a product that
would do like.
You.
Know complex super computing for
multidisciplinary optimization
of physics where the aerospace
market was definitely not the
hottest idea, right yeah, yeah,
but I think you know that what
is nice is I do think the
culture in Silicon Valley
embraces this sort of anybody
with an idea can come there
right and you know ideas are
cheap right so it's all about
the building and the execution
so.
Yeah.
It's in a very meritocratic
place, like, unlike like many
other sort of games, so to
speak, in life.
I feel like Silicon Valley is
quite meritocratic, right?
Where sort of anybody can be the
next like Zuck.
And so everybody kind of has to
be nice to each other and help
each other.
And so, you know, it's yeah, it
has a nice.
I think that dynamic is really,
there's a lot of paying it forward, like a lot of founders help
each other.
People are very accessible,
right.
So for me that was yeah, it was
a it was a great journey.
It was, it was pretty tough
though.
Like I like I was saying, I was
pitching this company.
Yeah, yeah.
That, you know, the exact
opposite of social, local, mobile.
There's like literally that if
you have the Venn diagrams, we
would be the one that like does
not overlap with anything that
like investors were interested
in at that time.
But you know, everything goes
through these waves, right?
And so I do think eventually,
like, you know, if you just have
a good mission, you're on,
right?
Like you'll find some funding,
Like it is a there's a lot of
investors, right?
And so ultimately you just need
one to write a check.
Yeah, yeah.
So what was the first few years
like?
What were the some standout
moments?
Who were the was a turning
point from a big investor or
like in those early days, 2011,
what when did you really feel
that he was going to work out?
Because I guess there were
moments when you maybe thought,
OK, I should just stop doing
this and get a job somewhere
else.
Yeah, I mean, I think like, you
know, what you call working out
versus like success, these are
all like your own definition, I
would say, right, Like so and
that definition for most people
changes over time.
I remember making a promise to
my significant other at the
time, we were not married yet
that, you know, like I'll just
do this thing.
And she was working really hard
and and, you know, like really
grinding.
And I was just kind of sitting
in our, I was working really
hard, but I was just writing
software and not making any
money and, and she was paying
the rent.
And so we sort of made this deal
where like, OK, well, if you
know, let's, you know, at what
point are you going to say, how
can I get a get a real job,
right?
And my parents were wondering
the same thing.
And we basically said, well,
like, you know, let's give it
two years.
And if you can pay yourself a
salary of something, right?
Like enough to clear like the
minimum medical benefits and
things like that, then that's a
win, right?
Like that, then we can keep
going basically.
So that was kind of the.
Deal I made with her and.
I think that's you know, like,
like, yeah, I would say really
made it it it changes all the
time.
If I think if you have the
ambition and sort of the mission
that we're on, right?
It's a it's a very big mission,
right?
And so, you know, I think I
think we still have a lot of our
work cut out for us even today,
right?
But but some big milestones,
important lesson I think for
founders is also like, you know,
I think Paul Graham says this
like, you know, companies don't
die, founders give up, right?
And you can't just keep going
right now.
There's there's a limit probably
like you take market feedback,
you're like, Hey, is this still,
is this investable?
Is this like smart?
Like did you learn some new
things?
But if you're kind of iterating
quickly, you're learning a lot
of things.
You're adapting your company to
like meet the market, so to
speak, right?
Kind of get this product market
fit and then any set of like
really smart people that, that
work really hard together and
sort of have these attributes
they, they will build success,
right?
Like, and so I think it is in
that way an amazing place where
you can kind of pursue, pursue
what you want to do.
For us, a big milestone was
first check.
So the first investor is always
very special for us.
That was, you know, we'd gone
around like pitched all these
like VCs kept getting turned
down.
And at this point we were doing
Y Combinator.
And you know, Paul Graham teed
up like one of his buddies.
It's like, OK, just give him the
pitch.
Here's the thing, I followed
exactly the playbook that he
gave me and you know, we didn't,
we didn't know what price, what,
you know, amount of the company
we should give up for, for
whatever investment around.
We're just trying to get some
investor right.
And it was like, OK, well, like,
like, how about these terms or
whatever based on guidance from
Paul Graham.
And, you know, eventually he
goes through a bunch of things
and still don't invest.
So I come back to Paul and I'm
just like, man, you know, we did
everything you said.
This is like the, you know, 50th
time and, you know, we didn't
get the check and but but you
know, I did follow like all the
things that you said, right?
And so like, why don't you just
invest?
And he's like, sure, he whips
out his checkbook and writes a
check.
And, and I think that was very
special.
Not really about the actual
dollar amount invested.
It was much more about his, you
know, when somebody kind of
makes a bet on you like that,
right?
And it's like real money out of
his pocket.
It, you know, means so much to
you that I'm sure you've seen
this with maybe like a thesis
advisor or other people who've
been in your career in the past.
That that is a a really special
moment, right?
And I think that certainly gave
me a lot of confidence to kind
of just keep, keep going.
And eventually we, we got lots
of great investors, but that was
that was a special one.
Another one was, you know, we,
we'd started working with some
early customers like we couldn't
raise money.
So we just like built the
product and started to get who
wants to go run like large scale
CFD in the cloud, right?
And it's like, you know, there's
like Boeing, Airbus, etcetera.
At that time there were these
really small space companies,
we're talking about like 50
person companies, right?
And we went to, there were
basically only two private space
companies at the time.
We went to both of them and
because of my aerospace
background, I've known some
people that working there.
So we're able to kind of chat
with them and eventually we sort
of got them on the hook that
they they would do this right.
And that that was also very
special because I think that's
when you kind of.
Could see hey.
Like, and they're making a bet
on you, right?
And, and, you know, when the
company is like one or two
people, it's very personal,
right?
So when these with these first
few customers, like at this
point, I had my Co founder,
who's my old boss from Boeing,
Adam McKenzie join.
And, you know, we sit there in
the room with some of these like
aerodynamicists and they're just
like this concept of putting it
in the cloud is, is pretty
foreign.
And remember, like web services,
So AWS had just started and web
services are built for like
almost the exact opposite of
HPC, right?
Like it, it's like very loosely
coupled, very, you know, you
kind of have to write your
software very tolerant to
failure, etcetera.
The actual performance is like
not great.
And so it, you know, but you
could kind of see where this was
going.
And so we pitched these
companies and I think that was a
big breakthrough when when they
were like, yes, we'll buy the
software, We'll pay something
for this basically right.
And we'll buy the software and
again, that was many iterations
to get there.
But once you get that
breakthrough, I mean, that was
very exciting, right?
And and those little wins along
the way, I think it's like at no
point, I think the entire
journey I felt like I've really
made it.
Yeah.
But you know, like I, I think
those are very material in those
early days, right?
Like like just just getting off
the ground.
I think many great ideas just
don't have enough energy on
execution put behind them,
right?
And, and even to this day,
right, like I still have people
come to me and be like, well, I
mean, we're doing much more than
just HPC these days.
But you get some, you know, you
still have this sort of old
network of HPC people, you know,
I both know who we're talking
about and.
You know there'll be.
People who say you get both
messages, right?
There were people at that time
who were like, you get these
Silicon Valley investors who
were like, what do you mean like
HPC, Like it already exists,
It's cloud computing and it's
AWS, right?
So you have that class of people
which are basically sort of the,
yeah, it's like it's already
been done.
Like why are you wasting your
time on this?
And then you have the other
class, which are the HPC people,
right?
Like it's super computing.
And these these folks are like,
this is absolutely impossible,
like never possible.
All that hardware is not good
enough, like etcetera.
And you have an entire ecosystem
that these days it's a little
bit different, right?
But remember then it was like
nobody was really doing this and
nobody believed it was really
possible.
And then you have people who
say, well, I had that idea.
Right, as if having the idea is
an important thing.
Yeah, I think the execution is
the the big thing that really
matters.
And that's where like those
traits of a good founder, I
think you, you, you know,
willing to persevere.
If you look at most companies,
if you're just willing to kind
of go for more than a decade,
most of the companies are very
successful, right?
But it's not easy, right?
So like I, I think that's also
like, it's not for everybody.
Well, and, and I was thinking
that you were probably really
facing an uphill battle because,
you know, if I look at from a
technology point of view, you
know, the hyperscalers took
quite a long time to really
have, for example, the
interconnect.
You, you, you know, like when I
joined AWS in what 2020, things
like EFA or they, they were
quite new.
So you were, did you feel that
was part of the challenge before
that, the hyperscalers that I
guess you know, you were
simplifying the use of when
moving as quick as you wanted in
terms of like technology?
Yeah, very good question because
like that was the remember we
started in 2011, right.
So there were some some days in
the wilderness there, but.
With cloud computing was kind of
really gaining traction, right?
And even back then, you got to
remember people were way
underestimating these markets by
like X, right?
Like from where it is today?
It shows how difficult it is.
Even when you see something
happening, it's like very
difficult to forecast, right?
We could talk about AI later,
yeah.
Early on, a big one was always
like, well, like, like why do I
need Rescale, right?
Like I could just go to a cloud
company and get this myself,
right?
And so and.
A lot of people perceived even
to this day, probably people
perceived the cloud companies
that are very close partners as
like competitors in this market
and that's sort of the wrong
framing.
The reality was I would be going
in at that time.
It was going to be Andy Jassy
and begging him to build
InfiniBand networking and
begging him to build like Specs
that.
Would do really well for this
market, right?
And the answer often wasn't
necessarily no, but it was like,
well, an incremental dollar
spent today, you know, I'm
better off just building more,
let's call it for simplification
commodity compute like because
there's more market share to
grab there versus this like
specialized compute, everything
costs X more, workloads are much
more volatile, etcetera,
etcetera, etcetera, right.
So there were sort of many
reasons to not do it.
There's also like some real
difficult networking challenges
like security challenges.
So the the way you build like a
cloud.
Service as, as you know very
well is a little bit different
than the HPC system, right.
And so at that time, the
maturity wasn't there to easily
sort of pursue this market, but.
But from first.
Principles, it seems like a
really a lost opportunity,
right, because if you kind of
look at it, it's like, well, you
know, commodity compute great.
Like the whole thing about AWS
was, hey, it was built for
scaling e-commerce peak loads
during the like, Black Friday or
something, right?
And but you know, like the rest
of the time and even today, like
if you just look at it wasn't
the money makers at AWS, it's
like the simple, it's just like
EC2, S3 like basic stuff, right?
And most people consume just
that what and super computing
and high performance computing
was always the case is that, you
know, these systems are super
expensive.
So time sharing them only the
biggest companies in the world
or the biggest labs could afford
to kind of build these systems,
right?
And it makes a lot of sense to
share those systems, right,
because they're so expensive,
right?
So share the CapEx investment,
the sort of timeshare of these
systems, so?
Used to be like mainframe time
sharing, but like with cloud
this becomes so much easier.
And so like it really did seem
like that was A at that time
like a a lost opportunity and as
Rescale we did make a conscious
choice.
It's like we are not at least at
that time, right.
We're not going to go get into
this CapEx game like the venture
capital dollars are not made.
You can see that today with
these.
AI companies in the
infrastructure side are not
really made for, you know,
making big CapEx compute
investments, right.
And so, yeah, we would be trying
to work really closely with the.
Cloud providers to actually
build the right infrastructure
for our customers.
But you could kind of see where
it's going, right?
Like at that time it was to me
again, I thought it was late.
It was pretty obvious that like
this is a great market.
Opportunity, right, But like
yeah, yeah, I think of the eyes
of say somebody like Andy Jassy
or you know, Satya was running
advanced computing at that time
in Azure.
I think they made some smart
bets too, I think.
I think they, yeah, HPC is still
this like small sub segment that
seems very difficult relative to
all of computing.
So all these things are all
about your frame, right?
Like if you come from the HPC
frame, this seems like pretty
obvious I think.
If you come from the, you're
running like the fastest
growing, most successful cloud
company in the world, like, you
know, there's many bets you
could be making.
And yeah, it took a while to get
this one off the ground even
today.
And as far as I understand,
there's no InfiniBand
networking at at AWS.
No, that's, that's true.
And we should say as well, I
guess that when we use the term
HPC and I guess the relevant
first discussing this is, I mean
you can argue, but I would say
from a hardware point of view,
what AI training needs today has
many, many, many of the same
components as HPC.
There's some subtleties, but in
terms of a low latency network,
that's basically what AI
training needs as well.
So interestingly, like the
reason that we're talking about
prior in those early days, it
was only really for loosely
coupled, wasn't it, from like a
hardcore performance point of
view.
So my question is, do you think
those early days almost made it
harder to convince people when
there was actually the hardware?
Are you still getting people who
are like it's it's slow running
on the cloud or there's a
because they they're still just
thinking back to the mid-2010s when maybe the hardware
wasn't there.
Do you know what I mean?
Are people lazy to be thinking
of what's current?
Yeah, and and like you and I are
probably on the same side of the
table on this, but, but I think
if I had to steelman, like
what's the sort of reason to not
not go to cloud, right?
Like a lot of people bring up
costs and we can talk about
that.
But I think if I'm sort of put
my hat on as one of our
customers, right like like a
manufacturing company it seems
if you're.
Certainly starting a new company
like like really obvious.
To to sort.
Of buy this compute as a service
as opposed to start building
your own data centers etcetera,
right?
Like unless there is some sort
of reason that's your
competitive advantage, right?
I can tell you Boeing thought it
was their competitive advantage.
They probably still take that to
this day.
And yeah, there's, there are
some I would say like edge cases
where it can make sense.
But in general, right, you want
to kind of a provider.
Like any major cloud provider
has way better economics, has
way more efficient sort of
scale.
The better supply chain they
have like better hardware,
faster, they are able to refresh
and resell your old hardware if
you want to rotate to new SKUs
and things like that.
So there's so many benefits if
you just.
Look at solving the real problem
you're trying to solve as a
manufacturer, say running a
simulation faster or designing a
vehicle faster.
That's the real problem you're
trying to solve, right?
The problem I think in HPC.
Is there's an entire industry
that's been set up with a
different framing, which is like
I'm, I'm actually here to most
efficiently invest in CapEx, run
the infrastructure into the
ground, try to efficiently use
this infrastructure, you know,
depreciate it in a really smart
way.
But it's all about this sort of
IT/TCO sort of frame, right?
And.
Purely on that frame, maybe
sometimes on-prem is competitive
with cloud, right?
But but if you even value a
little bit like actual
performance, which is in the
name of the industry, right,
like high performance computing,
the simple sort of to me.
The concept is, is like, well,
who do you want to bear the
CapEx?
Do you want it to be some really
low cost of capital, very big
cloud infrastructure player,
right?
Should that be you, right, as as
a manufacturer and especially
with the sort of rotating to new
infrastructure, there's a lot of
complexity, right.
So typical organization might be
running, you say 50 different
physics codes.
Right.
Each of these have different
algorithms, some of them have
different sub algorithms within
those algorithms, right,
Different ways of running them.
And so there's like 10s of
thousands of combinations and
way to run this.
Then they can all be compiled
differently.
They have different optimal
architectures.
Right.
And it's sort of like, and then
you run them sporadically at
different types like so if
you're a automotive company,
there's a big part of the design
cycle in detailed design.
You know, this is happening a
lot.
There's other times where you
may not be running so much and
so it is pretty tough.
I think for the average
enterprise like you know,
consumer of HPC to sort of say,
you know, it makes sense to kind
of run your own HPC.
Now if you look at the market
today, right, it's, it's about
20% cloud and say 80% on-prem,
which which you know, I don't
know, blows my mind still today,
right.
I think there is a, you know,
it's a big.
Switching costs takes a long
time.
If you're running and operating
data centers, you're maybe
depreciating that you know if.
It's a CFO making a decision
maybe six years, right?
And so even if you said 100% to
cloud tomorrow, it's it still
takes a long time, right?
And there's a lot of
complexities that I think are
glossed over.
So I think a big reason you
didn't see it take off earlier
was a lot of this complexity.
It is actually very hard to run,
say, a fluid dynamics code.
On an HPC system, very scalably,
very reliably and continuously
keep the codes updated.
And like when you run different
algorithms, they scale
differently and sort of like
what's the right cluster size
so.
There's so much that goes into
that.
That is, it's still, you know,
it's a specialized field right
now, at Rescale we write
software to simplify all that.
Right.
And try to sort of abstract away
all this complexity, but it's
quite complex and if you really
dig into it.
If you ask the people who are on
the sort of still running on-prem systems, they would often
tell you the biggest reason why
is, is sort of this it is hard
and you have to, you have to be
willing to kind of reinvent
yourself, right?
So like, just imagine if you're
a high performance computing
administrator for like 1 of the
top three aerospace companies in
the world, right?
All you've done last 20 years is
basically figure out how to
procure like the right
infrastructure, you know, 18
months of like.
Procurement processes get these
systems tested up and running
service, you know your different
engineering customers, internals
to your organization.
With cloud, it's a completely
different paradigm.
Like that entire paradigm is
like sort of hardware up
thinking, right?
Which is like it sort of starts
with the processor and then you
build out the systems.
I think the right way to think
about.
What is the purpose of HPC is
ultimately to serve the
workloads with good performance.
And that's more like workload
down thinking, right?
So like it's really just about
OK, like for this workload, what
is actually the right
infrastructure, what's the right
price, what's the right
performance, etcetera.
Like how are you going to
optimize that problem?
And with an elastic system,
you're going to solve that
problem much more elegantly,
right?
So I would say that's a very
long answer, but I think it's
still to this day, you know,
there's people who believe.
Like HPC should be done on-prem
Yeah I.
I see that my big observation is
always just timelines that
everything, as you say, just
takes so much longer than people
realize.
So, you know, when I started, I
remember and this is This is why
I'm still amazed by you having
these ideas nine years earlier
that people were like completely
anti cloud.
A lot of people were anti cloud.
And then you know, just as the
time as I was leaving, I
remembered that it wasn't, are
we going to do that?
It was like how, how we could,
oh, no, that's not true.
It was probably hybrid, hybrid
and we are going to do some of
it on, but we'll still keep
some.
And that depended whether it's
to start upon enterprise.
But I definitely saw a shift.
But then I thought that means
the time then to do a PoC to then
roll it out to change like so.
It's probably, I guess you'd
agree there's probably even more
upside in cloud to come because
it takes so long to convince
people and then for them to
change that we may not see that
consequence for another few
years.
Yeah, I think that's right.
I do think that, you know,
Rescale, we're really focused on
solving kind of like what is the
real problem the customer's
trying to solve, right?
And so often it's again, using
this example of a manufacturer
might be an engineer doing sort
of fluid dynamic simulation.
They just want to run that
simulation as efficiently as
possible and like all this other
stuff.
And so they're like all the IT
stakeholders trying to kind of
serve that user ideal, right?
You kind of work from that
customer backwards.
I think you really want to solve
this.
Problem more from first
principles as opposed to.
Sort of you have all this
baggage of these like on-prem
systems, hybrid, all this stuff,
right?
And our view is sort of like,
well, if we can give you a
service that is the optimal
router, right?
So they can real time say, OK,
you're going to run this fluid
dynamics code.
You know, we understand some of
the metadata, right?
So we say, hey, it has like, you
know, 500,000 cells or whatever,
right?
And say you're running STAR-CCM+.
We know that version of STAR-
CCM+, how well it scales.
We we know like with that kind
of cell model, like what's the
size cluster that should go on,
right.
And then you go through this
sort of what we've built as a
compute recommendation engine.
So you actually so say, OK, you
can plug in your own on-prem
resource.
So that's one of the fixed
resources you could choose from.
It comes at some price layer
internal sort of cost to
operate.
Maybe they have your cloud
resources, right.
And then, you know, just have
one, you have all the major
cloud providers, you have neoclouds, maybe have some special
supercomputing relationships
with universities, etcetera.
In this whole network, hundreds
of architecture choices, right?
All of these had a little
nuances, right?
Oh, but that's an Intel
processor.
So you need to use Intel MPI or
like hey here this like version
of this code.
Like needs to be compiled
differently whatever.
So it's a, it's a we want an
analysis in this little data,
but how many combinations are
there is like more than 50
million combinations.
So it's like, how do you solve
that problem?
Well, you basically want to go
through some sort of algorithm
and we.
Recommendation system was kind
of our solution to this problem
to automatically kind of figure
figure out and route that right.
And that's now you have the
service for this user for any
workload.
That you know, you can kind of
use both the all the metadata
and all the knowledge Rescale
has from running many of these
similar workloads before, but
you can also leverage any of the
resources you want.
In the way you as an
administrator can say, hey,
like, I first want to fill up my
own system or whatever, right?
And that is, I think that's the
right way to solve this problem,
right?
And it is, it is a pretty
technical way, right?
I think there's also like
usability of this is, is super
important.
So for us, how this shows up is
literally like you open up
Rescale, you drag in your like
input file, right?
Or if you upload the input file
and you and you select the
software, you press run, right?
It is that simple.
But in that is this highly
complex Configurator which can
kind of optimize and solve these
problems for you.
And, you know, I, I think that's
a.
Great way to solve this problem.
But like you said, like there's
a, there's a lot of practical
challenges, right?
Like, so that's the technical
person and he says, OK, like
this is a great solution, right?
There's a lot of practical
things in enterprise software.
And like go to market and like
how do you use customers like
transition and etcetera.
So that are still challenges for
customers today.
But I think increasingly, like
you said, it's easier and
easier.
Like this PoC process you
described, you got to remember,
like if you're buying on-prem,
you're probably going through
like a sort of 9 to 12 month
like procurement process at a
minimum, right?
For many companies, it's closer
to 18 months.
You go through all this
evaluation, then your system is
finally live 18 months later.
And that's just not like, you
know, if you're an engineer
trying to run this.
Fluid dynamic simulation, you
can't do that right?
Like you got to solve the
problem in a different way,
right?
And I do think today if you go
to Rescale, right, and go
through this process, you can do
this all in like 5 minutes,
right?
But there are practical
challenges.
So if you think again, think of
a like a large enterprise
organization, there's a lot of
new ways of thinking that's sort
of required.
And it comes back I think to
like the courage, right?
Like are you, are you willing
to?
Say, hey, like we got to do it a
different way and I know I'm
going to go through lots of
challenges, etcetera.
But and I think increasingly a
lot of companies are seeing so
much success that it is hard to
argue the other way, right?
Like if I had to argue where if
you're using cloud, like if I go
to on-prem.
Yeah.
There's a few reasons, but for
most organizations this would
make very little sense.
And I guess now it seems, and I
didn't predict it, but it seems
to be happening that there's
even more because of you see, sort of,
neoclouds, which I guess has
been really because of AI.
There seems to be even more
competition to the big cloud
providers.
I guess there's more options,
but even more reason to have a
single place to route that
through.
Because if you have an if you
have accounts with cloud
providers A, B, C, D and E, for
that enterprise to build out all
themselves.
I mean it can be done.
But it's a lot of work.
Does it make it even more
valuable to have like a go
between it than it was when
there was mainly just AWS as the
biggest one?
Yeah, I think.
Now of course we can, we can
optimize within a single cloud,
right?
So like if a customer really
loves Microsoft or Amazon or
Google like we can, we can
certainly do that and and you
sort of solve the problem at a
smaller scale.
I think there's this margins
piece, there's the speed, right?
That's why I think.
You see the neoclouds as
well, like they're just able to
stand up a cluster much faster,
like it is the bigger
organization is it is hard,
right?
And it's pretty.
Interesting to see Microsoft
that they outsource a lot of
their GPU compute to CoreWeave,
right?
So public information, you know,
there's, there's a few dynamics
I think why like 1 is.
Sort of just pure GPU scarcity.
So like they just have them, not
only GPUs, they also have the
power infrastructure, right?
Like I'm sitting in a data
center working to power them and
cool them.
So there's sort of that timing
effect, but there is a setting
up.
Those systems are like HPC
systems, right?
And that is very different than
building public cloud resources
historically.
Now, if you only have like one
or two customers, you can build
these bespoke systems, right?
Like, like what cloud provider
to get at is serving thousands
or 10s of thousands, millions of
customers, right?
And so there's a challenge for a
neocloud is how do you scale
that?
There's also, I think an element
of, but the speed really
matters.
Like I, I think right now in AI,
it's just all about speed,
right?
And so people are willing to do
absolutely crazy.
Thanks for speed, right?
And it's because of the sort of
ultimate end-use case like this
sort of AI war between all the
big tech companies is fueling
all of that, right.
And and if you're just a few
months faster, I'm training a
large language model that can
make a big.
Difference right in in the long
term game here.
And so it's, it's, it's
interesting the bottlenecks,
right?
Like if you, I don't know if
you've been following this, but
there's like, it's all these neoclouds
of course.
But there's also these practical
problems people are running
into, like there's not enough
electricians to, like, you know, build
data centres, right?
And there's like, you know,
like, like a meta doesn't have
enough like buildings.
So they'd like operating data
centers in tents, right?
Like, and then there's like this
really efficient cooling systems
built by NVIDIA that like run
super efficiently.
But then like xAI is, is is like
literally like, like using
generators to do sort of cool
water and pump it into the
cooling system in the Super
inefficient way.
But they, they got their
training model up much faster
than anybody else, right?
And so like, yeah, like running
fast matters here.
And that's probably where, to be
fair, the, there is a difference
between the HPC for CAE and the,
and the HPC for AI because it's
probably true.
If if you're a very large AI
company where you need so much
compute, but it's basically just
for you, you could probably
argue that it might be actually
better for you to build it
yourself.
If that's your core
differentiator is to get that
training model out.
Two months later, you can kind
of see like, why would we go and
wait on a cloud?
We can just do it ourselves.
We, we have the same type of
GPU.
We have 100,000 of them.
That's it.
Then it's I can see the logic
but for most manufacturing
companies or aerospace
companies, they don't have
100,000 GPUs to train one model
right?
It's a different world.
So I guess it's different needs
as you say.
And probably they don't have 150
different applications, legacy
applications like CAE does.
I guess the AI world is
something newer.
Yeah, I do think like you know,
AI is is changing a lot and you
know the CAE engineering world
as well, right.
And, and we could talk more
about that, but like you spend a
lot of time talking about the
HPC layer.
I think the way, if you sort of
Fast forward to Rescale today,
right?
Like the way the way we look at
it today is there's the HPC
layer or the compute layer, but you have the data layer,
super important, right?
Like, so, so one of the big
argue like, OK, why do these big
training models?
Why, why are these then sort of
on-prem is like a natural
question, right?
Like, but like if you're sort of
the downloading entire web and
then like training on that,
that's a very heavy data gravity
kind of situation, right?
And of course you want that data
as close as possible to the
compute.
So there's always like memory
implications.
There's there's how these, you
know, all the detailed
architecture really matters, but
also it's like, how do you serve
all these things?
So that's one, I would say class
of HPC problems.
But data starts, you know, it's
true that some of this is only
for these large LLM providers.
But you know, I think everybody
like if I speak with our
customers, they're all building
AI models themselves as well.
And these are much smaller
scale.
But ultimately they need
efficient infrastructure to
train their own data as well.
Yeah.
And then obviously inference is
a big one too, right?
And like running inference
efficiently is going to get
really important right today,
you know, if you if you sort of
breakdown the economics.
So like Silicon Valley is
funding a lot of very cheap
services, right?
Why?
Because everybody wants to win
the AI platform war, so to
speak, right?
And so people are willing to
lose a lot of money today on
inference, right?
Just to win the customer, right?
But over over time, all these
economics need to be figured out
and things do need to be run
actually efficiently, right?
And so a manufacturer, because
here say a Tier 1 manufacturer
and automotive, you're kind of
running your it's like a 5–10%
margin business often, right?
And so it's like you already
have to run really efficiently.
Why that's why IT focus so much
on TCO.
That's that's why it's like,
hey, I can run like the system
for like 10 years and divide it,
you know, like it all makes
sense to me.
But I think if you think about
the engineering.
Problems you want to solve if
you're a little bit, you know
for thinking of like OK, you
know how to get out of being a
10% margin business as a.
Tier one supplier, right?
It's I think the way out is
actually using the latest
technologies, which is, you
know, there's, there's a compute
layer, but especially your data,
say you're a seat manufacturer.
I know how to like do seat
design really well.
And I might be really good at
crash simulation, right?
And so and so have all this
crash simulation data.
If I'm like one of the top three
companies in seat manufacturing,
I probably have some of the best
crash simulation data for seats
out of anybody, right?
If you can build what we call
some of these like AI physics
models around that, you can
build a lot of the intelligence
into a much more compressed
timeline, right?
So now instead of like trying to
speed up the algorithm, you're
actually like changing the
algorithm and going to from
deterministic to probabilistic.
But then maybe I can serve my
OEM like way faster, like not a
little bit faster.
Like I can actually say, hey,
like I, I think I could do that
seat with like 98% confidence
and I could give you that answer
in maybe an hour instead of like
2 months of analysis, right?
And so this is, that's, I think
where the future's headed.
And then like you have, that's
on the simulation side.
Then there's also this, you
know, we're working with
customers to build sort of
engineering agents.
Right.
It's like.
You, you kind of get this
capability to this, you're
actually starting for the
simulation engineers.
They have this this automotive
company empowering them to just
do their job like way faster.
So all the mundane tasks you're
starting to sort of automate,
right?
And that's I think every
function and every industry
frankly is going to go through
that sort of process, right.
The nice thing in engineering is
there is a lot of data and
there's a lot of like
intelligence already built into
all these processes, etcetera.
And so it's Rescale with our
customers.
We're in a unique position where
we, I think, have a really good
understanding of like how the
actual end user engineer or
scientist runs all these work
flows.
What are the problems they're
trying to solve?
It can help them do that, you
know, 10 times better.
Everybody wants, right?
And this entire compute
conversation, right, becomes
pretty secondary, right, Because
it's sort of like, you know,
like that's just it's just
electricity, right?
It's it's like you're just
powering the ability for an
engineer or scientist to come up
with a cool innovation.
Well, that's kind of yeah, a
good segue to talk about that a
little bit more.
The you're right, we basically
focused on HPC. HPC was pre-AI, the
big changer, you know, you have
more HPC run your simulation
faster and it still is, don't
get me wrong.
And of course you know, GPUs
help that, but the AI feels very
transformative for engineering.
So I mean, how have you seen
that convergence on the Rescale
platform and from customers that
you're speaking to, You know,
are they still just dabbling and
with their sort of more in the
R&D phase, how much more sort of
AI training or AI surrogates are
they doing next to their
traditional CAE?
How are you seeing that you're,
you're at the front with
customers?
How is that transition?
The yeah, it's happening really
fast, you know, are let's say
our most innovative and fast
adopting customers.
They have AI based automation.
You called agentic kind of
things built in.
They have they're definitely
doing AI surrogates.
They are really thinking ahead
of like what's the sort of let's
just assume we already have AI
surrogates, right?
Like what are the next level of
problems we can solve?
Because once you have AI
surrogates and sort of, you
know, domain I'm I'm pretty
familiar with is things like in
the, in the multi physics space,
right?
Like you're always trying to
kind of to reduced-order modelling or some way to
simplify these highly complex
kind of large scale models?
And sort of.
If you're say building an
airplane, you have this
conceptual design phase where
you're like, it's smart to use
like carbon fiber as a material
system for this airplane where
all the implications.
The challenge with that is
always like we get to the
detailed design that that's when
all the details like it really
matter.
And it'll be like, you know, at
the at the base of like a
commercial aircraft, you might
have 100 to 200 plies of carbon
fiber.
And then you have this like bolt
that comes through there into
the titanium fitting.
And there's like a bunch of
rules on like how that bolt
supposed to interact with the
system and all this kind of
stuff, right?
And it'll be like, OK, like we
really need 200 carbon fiber.
Plies at that root, right?
But then it'll be like, well, we
can't just go from 200 carbon
fiber plies to like 10 in the
next panel over.
Like this needs to go very sort
of slowly, like reduce it by 10%
sort of every panel because you
can't have this disproportionate
kind of stress situation, right?
And then it's like, oh, well,
this panel, we need actually be
able to make it.
And you know, like our tool
forming process can only handle
XYZ.
So there's a lot more that
detail drives an enormous amount
of the actual design.
And the problem has always been
is like in that conceptual
design phase, how the historic
has been done, you get a lot of
really smart people in the room.
And you say, yeah, this seems
like the right decision because
I've seen some test data on
carbon fiber over here and I've
like run some experiments over
there.
But what you really want to do
is kind of take all that really
detailed complex information and
synthesize it up to help make
one of these kind of higher
level decisions, right?
And what AI surrogates allow you
to do is to simplify that
compression process.
I do agree that it is, you know,
the criticism is like, hey, this
is misleading.
You can, you can run the
simulation 10,000 times faster,
etcetera.
I mean, it is, it depends on
your frame of reference whether
that's true or not.
But like what what is absolutely
true is that using neural networks
to compress this highly complex
information, right and solve
next sort of generation problems
that you would never even
attempt before, right?
Are now possible, right?
And and you have this much more
elegant process to sort of
capture the intelligence of your
engineering organization.
So and you can look do that at
the, you know, individual
discipline solver level, right?
But you can also do that at
higher levels.
And then you can start
incorporating, you know, these
sort of things like
manufacturing constraints and
things like that.
And if you can, you know, the,
the faster you can do that loop
basically, right, like the
better design you will get.
Like I think what people are
usually surprised by is that
that loop, there's exceptions to
this, but that loop takes a long
time.
Like in in typical aerospace
company, both Airbus and Boeing of
this sort of like loop of just
like all the different
engineering disciplines to sort
of say, OK, to have this shape
wing based on this ship, we're
going to have these like loads
in the system based on these
loads, like this sort of
mechanical team is going to like
decide what kind of like
structure we can do because of
the structure, it's going to
bend a certain way, which then
comes back to like, OK, that's
the shape of the wing at cruise,
right?
And so you have this big loop
and that loop takes like three
to four months.
It could take like an hour,
right?
Like if you sort of said, hey,
I'm not constrained by compute.
You're just running a whole
bunch of software, right?
You still need some really smart
people to make some smart
decisions, right?
Like it doesn't totally
eliminate the engineer.
No.
But, but I do think that that's
where the industry is going.
Our customers like the the
bleeding edge customers, they
are implementing all this stuff
right now and it's all possible
today.
Like the exciting thing now is
like, hey, it's right there.
You just have to do it.
That's exactly that's the way I
normally describe it to people
is that, you know, 10 years ago
there used to be this dream of
real time CAE that, you know,
HPC would become so fast that
you could do the simulation in
real time.
But it actually is impossible.
You know, there's various
reasons why a traditional
structures or fluid solver will
never really become real time.
And that's where it's, I feel
the AI surrogates, because by
definition they can be real
time, does allow for the more
agentic AI.
Because how can you really have
an agentic AI system when one of
the agents is a solver that
takes 12 hours to run?
Like, yeah, you can do that, but
it, it doesn't feel like the end
goal.
The end goal should be like
Google Gemini just because I
happen to use that one.
There's others where like I want
to ask it to do something for
me.
I don't want to wait 12 hours to
get the answer back.
It feels like you want it to
come in a short time and I feel
like the AI surrogates plug into
that AI agent theme more easily
if you know what I mean.
I don't know if you agree.
Yeah, it's a good.
It's an interesting way for any
and I guess the way I look at it
is you have kind of, you know,
just like you have deep
research, it takes a lot longer
and then you have also like
quick responses.
It's just like that, right?
Like where it's like, hey, if I
am a designer and I just want to
change the shape of a mirror,
right, I can get an instant
aero response that's like 99%
accurate.
That is awesome, right?
Like before, my alternative was
I changed the design, sent the
CAD model over to the aero
team.
Three days later they send me
back.
Hey, that, that create a lot of
drag, right?
So now you can get like a like a
pretty good answer and and
pretty good.
Like I've seen cases where this
is like over 99.9% accurate and
like, of course that depends on
like the data you train on and
all these kind of things.
But ultimately you can get these
responses back that dramatically
reduce the cycle.
So you just eliminated 3 days by
providing like a rough estimate
that's almost real time.
I still think that the detailed
simulations do really matter.
Like that's your training data,
right?
Like so like, and there's a
couple of parts there, right?
Like I think there's the, I call
it the sim-to-real gap, which is
a separate discussion.
But that's, it's another, I
think, interesting element,
which is like, OK, are these
simulations that we're running,
how accurate are they?
Because the real ground-truth
data, right?
It's not even wind tunnel
testing.
It's actually like the real
data, right?
And the wind tunnel is a proxy
for that.
And then your simulation tool is
a proxy for the wind tunnel.
And yes, all the physics
equations are correct, but
there's like a lot of little
things that still can, can
change, like real world
outcomes.
And so, but from the pure
simulation, you now have the
ability to generate and ground
all this data like very
efficiently with these AI
models, right?
And so like, yes, that designer
doesn't want to wait for like an
like, yeah, you can give them an
agentic capability spin off a
simulation, right?
That's not that useful to them,
right?
Where agentic to me means, and
you know, it's a kind of a
buzzword.
So everything's agentic these
days.
But to me it's more of this kind
of like like proactive thing,
right?
So where it's like, OK, here,
here's what happened.
And it'll sort of describe a
customer scenario, automotive
OEM, right?
And they have a supplier,
supplier say it's the seat
manufacturer, they changed the
design of the seat because some
reason for same
manufacturability on their end,
right?
That design change is is sort of
automatically synced this OEM,
this is happening because this
seat manufacturer is in Europe
and the OEM is in the US.
You know, this is happening at
like 2:00 AM right now because
that change happened.
You need to rerun your crash
analysis.
So you could do an instant
response of like sort of an AI
surrogate of like, hey, is this
going to be a is this look great
or is this bad?
And it's like this might be a
problem.
OK, now because of that and the
simulation engineer sleeping
because of that, a spin up like
LS-DYNA job to go run the crash
analysis and I'm just going to
run it for just this component,
the subcomponents, you know, in
a way that's like pretty
efficient based on a bunch of
rules.
I gave that agent right, which
said, hey, you can't spend more
than $1000 and if it design
change like this comes in,
always use the AI surrogate
first.
And now I, I want to, you know,
like failed that test, though,
right then then run this
simulation.
So when I come in in the
morning, right open my laptop at
7 a.m., I've got right there.
I have the simulation results
right to go review right?
And it's like it's.
Pre done the preprocessing,
this whole like trace of all
these things that happened is
presented to me in like a simple
way.
And you know, my job just got so
much faster and more efficient,
right, Like, like the real way
this happened before and and
most organizations work this way
is like, oh, this this CAD file
got zipped up, right, and then
it's like sat in somebody's
outbox, but they were in Europe,
so they were actually on
vacation for another week,
right.
And so like it didn't actually
get make it over to the OEM
because like whatever random
human delay, right, then the zip
file comes over and then
somebody has to do this
analysis, right?
And then, and then all these
sort of steps happen, right?
And I think if you can sort of
shorten that entire process now,
it's not perfect, right?
Like if you look at the tools we
have today, there's a lot of
expertise to make all these
judgements and do all these
things.
But you can already see today
that like our customers are
already doing this.
They're automating more and more
of this process, right?
And you're just going to get
comfortable with it.
It's just like you get
comfortable with using a Gemini
or ChatGPT or whatever, right?
And that's the sort of agentic
thing is sort of like.
Proactively doing all the kind
of like.
Grunt work that you don't want
to do right?
Yeah, but I, I seriously, I
don't know if I'm just, you
know, drinking the Kool-aid or
whatever the phrase is, but I, I
really can't see how this will
just totally change because.
Well, the first thing to say
maybe what, what I was
mentioning before is even if I
believe that you, the AI
surrogates, make it good enough,
you're still going to have a
whole load of huge HPC resources
to create training data.
You know, so even if the
surrogate models become good
enough, and unless there's some
breakthrough that I'm not aware
of, you still need all the
traditional stuff to, to
generate the data.
So actually it's, it's not a,
it's a replacement in that the
end user may primarily use it,
but in the back end, somebody's
still having to generate this
data to go and train the models
so that you're not truly
replacing it.
It may just be in the
background, if you know what I
mean, but I really feel that
the, the AI engineer thing seems
more and more real because what
you just described to me is
eventually through enough
training or awareness of
different agents, isn't it just
that I become like a manager?
So I have I and I have a team of
people who are not real people
who are doing this analysis for
me and I'm just looking at it at
the end.
Yes, and I think it's awesome,
right?
Like I think it's so so the
other part's like this is
already happening today.
So hopefully shortly we'll be
able to share some like maybe
public customer case studies and
exactly how this works and have
the customers talk about it.
But I think, you know, there's
no part what I just described,
right?
Like all all the components that
we have for any company to go do
that, you don't need a magic AI
surrogate model, right?
Like it's just like, but I think
the right framing is more AI
surrogates is 1 module of AI.
There's many AI modules in the
entire product development
engineering process, right?
Some of these are more
leveraging LLMs, right?
Like some of them are more like
this compute recommendation
engine.
That's like a totally different
category of AI.
But it helps solve this like
search problem much more
efficiently.
You have AI surrogates who do
these sort of probabilistic
physics analysis much more
efficiently.
The, the really nice part is the
productization of these because
like if I tried to steelman,
sort of the cynics and I've I've
heard many of them in sort of
the CAE space, right where it's
like, but those are not real
like engineering calculations.
These are just like
approximations, etcetera.
Approximations been around
forever.
We've always done surrogate.
Modeling right like the.
I think what's really important
is like, solve the real business
problem, right?
Like like solve actually what,
why are people even doing this
kind of work, right?
Like, well, they're just trying
to figure out the sort of
physics answer for something.
And almost all simulations that
are run are essentially a waste
because in the end, there's only
like one or two that really
matter that go into
certification and like the aero model for say a Boeing airplane,
right?
Like they're sort of if you want
the entire way of how did you
get there, right?
Like, yes, then all those other
data matters, right?
Like all the other experiments
that were run, but more than
like 99% of all those
computations that don't impact
this, like final design is
great, right?
And so the question is just
like, how can you go through
that search process as quickly
and as efficiently as possible?
And what changes everything is,
I think it's if you can solve
that search problem so much
faster, it changes how you do
engineering completely, right?
And not in a negative way,
right?
Like to me because, because
there's also like the other
criticism on this is like, OK,
well then we just replace all
these engineers.
Like I'm an engineer, like why
are you replacing me?
Right.
But this is all like, what is
your frame on technology and
like how the world should kind
of work, etcetera, right?
But like it's I think right it
it's super important to kind of
like jump on these waves as like
this is awesome.
Why is it awesome?
Well, what we just have to grind
through a whole bunch of CAD and
CAE modeling with like a team of
12 people for like 6 months to
get to this answer, not to get
the exact same answer with two
people in a week, right?
That is a win for everybody.
Those ten other people, right,
that you may not need any more
can go do five other projects.
Those ten other people can do
more meaningful things, learn
other things, right?
If you look at the history of
like CAD modelling, right?
Like it used to be, we have
these drafters I'm sure you've
seen these pictures of like, you
know, yeah, 100 people just
drafting the physical documents,
right, To be able to build
components.
I don't think it's a negative
thing that people don't need to
do this anymore.
Like you press a button in a 3D
CAD product and spits out like
so.
It's a productivity argument,
isn't it?
You know, yeah, you can do more
efficient.
I mean, there's a debate on
jobs.
I guess it's maybe the correct
thing to say is it's not the
job.
There will be people's jobs that
they don't need to do anymore,
but you'd hope they could trans
transition to a different job.
I guess is.
Yes, and like it's.
You know, the U.S. I think the job
retraining stat is something
like 20 to 30% do reskilling
every year.
Yeah, yeah.
So yes, unemployment stays at
like X level, right.
But like in the US statistic.
But I imagine it's similar
globally.
And I don't personally find it
very satisfying if you're like
if your job was like, say, just
drafting documents, right?
But actually, like, you can just
automate it with software.
It's right.
Not a very fun job.
Right.
Like no, no, no, hadn't.
There's just certain stuff.
I think that machines or AI now
can do better.
You know, if I have to manually
go through 50 simulations and
try and write a report, why this
one moved the vortex here and AI
could do exactly the same task
in less than a minute.
And then you can still write the
report and analyze and think
about it.
But you didn't have to do some
of that manual stuff that
probably took you half a day.
To do exactly so we've we've
actually done this with our
customers.
We survey them, right.
Let's say what part about your
job do you dislike do or where
you don't feel like you're
adding value?
One of the top things that come
up is exactly what you just
described is write all these
reports.
Guess what, it's really easy to
take a bunch of like simulation
files, right?
You've decided, hey, this is the
right sort of answer and here's
sort of the high level reasons
why.
And you can just generate a
report using AI tool that works
today.
There's no reason not to do
that.
Now, do you need to review the
report?
Yes, right, but like you can
shortcut a lot of the process,
which actually allows the person
or the human to add, you know,
spend much more time on those
like value added tasks, right.
And and I kind of think of this
always as like moving up a layer
of abstraction where now you can
do so much more.
I think what people
underestimate is like when you
change something, right, like
say the six month process down
to a week, that changes
everything, right?
It changes like industry
dynamics because like you can
now do product development so
much faster.
It changes like what kind of
innovations you can actually
build, right?
It changes like the org
structures of companies,
obviously, but I think that's
all, you know, like value added
to society, right?
Like I think it's great, yeah.
And.
I guess full circle.
The underpinning of all of this
is access to compute, basically.
That's right, isn't it?
I do think, I mean, I, I will
say like, you know, pre AI wave,
right?
And, and, and I think, yeah,
that's when you were probably at
AWS, you know, compute was
really considered like very much
a commodity that's like, yeah,
like there's all these like
complexities, even HPC, but like
in the end, it's just like sort
of a means to the end, etcetera.
I think AI has shown, which is
quite exciting how important
compute still is, right?
And they're sort of the, the
high level thing of like, hey,
well, you need this massive
scale compute to solve this,
specifically this sort of LLM training model.
But I think that analogy applies
to many other things.
So if you take a typical
engineering problem at a large
company, a complex problem like
like like high end aerospace
product, these people doing this
work are highly compute bound,
right?
And they're compute bound at
the, you know, I can only run so
many simulations, but they're
also compute bound at like as
you move up these layers of
abstraction, right?
As I sort of like this agentic
engineering, it becomes easier
and easier to actually like sort
of kick off a simulation, right?
Add more training data, all
these kind of things, right?
That's where you need to be
really smart about like, well,
what are all the, like design
points you want to run?
Again, AI can help you do all
these things, right?
But the compute bill sort of
going up and up and up.
However, in most organizations,
if you look at like, what is
your R&D spent, the biggest cost
is the people.
Yeah.
So this opportunity to get much
more leverage out of an
individual, right?
Like they can just add much more
value in this cycle is is
massive.
I think it is underpinned by
compute.
And if you don't have that
foundational building block,
right, like you're, you're
highly constrained.
The good thing is engineers can
always work around those
constraints.
You know, they just make do with
whatever you're given.
But you know, like those
constraints, like really
constrained also innovation,
right?
They constrain the ability, like
if you can make it, SpaceX is a
good example, right?
Like it like sort of back when I
was working at Boeing, it was
like, hey, there's a SpaceX
company and, you know, Boeing
thought they were pretty good at
like launching rockets and
putting satellites in orbit.
And you know, at SpaceX there
will take the cost.
I think of like putting a kilo
in space, like down by like 20
to 50 X depending on like kind
of what metrics you use, but a
minimum 20X, right?
Once you do that, right?
Like it opens up this entire
market, right?
Like it's like, OK, now you can
do Starlink, now you can do all
kinds of other stuff in space,
right?
And you want those expansion
opportunities.
I do feel like a lot of
industries are pretty stuck,
like the way Boeing builds an
airplane or Airbus for that
matter, right?
Is pretty stuck in sort of these
old ways, right?
And I think of the way you can
get out of that is using all
these new tools where it's sort
of like something is at least
10X better.
It totally changes not only like
how fast you can do the product
development, but also like the
markets you can serve.
It changes the way you work with
your customers.
If you're say, an aircraft
manufacturer right, and that
pushes society forward, I think
it's great.
I, I don't know about you, but
the older I get and the more I
work with enterprise and the
more I work with startups I
have, and it's probably not
practically possible, but I
often think, OK, if company A is
a legacy enterprise company and
they're trying to innovate and
come up with some new product.
I really do think their best
suggestion is they should go and
spin off a startup, right?
Because I sometimes feel as if
they cannot change into they
should literally go and take 50
super smart people, fund it and
let them do whatever the hell
they want and then integrate it
back.
Do you know what I mean?
Some companies are just too
stiff to really innovate.
Yes.
I don't.
Disagree.
I mean, I think it is much
harder to be running like one of
those companies and like
transform as an organization and
it's proven through all the
numbers, right?
Like like sort of the Fortune
500 companies, like, you know,
the stock market top companies
rotate like very quickly, right?
Like most companies don't last
like 15–20 years as a public
market company.
So I will say though, like, you
know, like we as Boom Supersonic
is one of our customers, right,
man, starting a supersonic jet
company, right?
I always think Rescale is like a
pretty tough company to run, but
that is hard, right?
But that really takes a lot of
courage, right, to do something
like that.
So it's very admirable for folks
who have the mission and willing
to kind of take that on.
But what is also true is that
like, so they're super
innovative.
They're adopting all these
methods.
They're going to be way faster
than any other kind of large
aerospace manufacturer trying to
do a supersonic jet, of course,
but it's still really hard,
right?
Like, like startups are just
really hard, right?
And, you know, I'm, I would say
I'm glad I'm, I work in the like
field of software, right?
But we, our customers are all
building hardware pretty much.
So it's, yeah, it's awesome to
be able to serve them.
But I think it's, well, that's
the right answer.
It is still like, you know, the,
the the odds are sort of stacked
against you when you start a
company, right?
And so even today, like boom
supersonic, right?
Like they, they, they flew that
airplane.
It's, it's like, built with Rescale.
Awesome, right to test airplane,
they got to, they build the real
one.
They got to get all these
customers, you know, and it's,
it's, it's, it's a tough, yeah,
it's a tough problem to solve as
a as a small company, right?
So, but, but that is the way
like I do think cultural change,
like culture really matters.
So one thing we focus on at
Rescale is like not only making
sure our customers are adopting
all these capabilities, right,
but like if you, if you work at
Rescale, we have this.
So being an AI first company is
completely changes how you run
the company yourself, right?
And so we're very focused on
that.
Like this whole thing you were
talking about, hey, now I'm
managing a bunch of agents.
So every employee at Rescale is
empowered to kind of like, you
know, run their agents, right?
And, and we are using every
single AI framework, right?
Like I'm testing all of them
usually in parallel at the same
time, very rapidly changing
landscape.
But I think the way you build a
company and the way you scale a
company is quite different in
this like world of when you have
this AI tooling.
And I do think as a as if you
consider Rescale a big or small
company, but as a 200 person
company versus say a 2000 person
company, we have a distinct
advantage.
Our ability to adopt new tooling
for this and sort of like dog
food and use all these tools
ourselves is, you know, if we
sort of execute well, is it
really fast, right?
Like we can, we can adopt new
tools really fast.
That allows us to understand how
our customers will also need to
like sort of change and adopt
tooling like this, right?
And, and it's a very different
business.
Our business is building
software.
Their business might be building
a vehicle, but a lot of the
principles are the same, right?
Like it, it's sort of like you
have to really rethink how you
do business and how you do
engineering and all these
things.
But I think that's also why it's
exciting, right?
Because it's like it is a new
paradigm.
These shifts don't happen very
often, right?
Like I don't know, if you asked
me a decade ago, are we going to
pass the Turing test, I'd have
been like, I don't think so,
right?
I would have been very wrong.
But like I think just like the
cloud shift like opened up these
like massive, massive markets
and and massive new
opportunities, right And many
businesses could not exist
without sort of concept of cloud
etcetera.
AI, I do think is even bigger,
right?
It is sort of like the probably
the biggest one of our
generation.
And that's awesome because like,
you know, I don't know if you
think about this, but I'm like,
man, what was it like when like
the I mean, I was a kid, like
the Internet sort of first came
out and then you could all of a
sudden like do this, like, you
know, you could sort of message
people across the world.
It's like it seemed crazy,
right?
And it was really a special
time.
And I think those, you know, you
go through the high of these
waves.
I think right now is a really
special time, right where we're
like the bleeding edge of
applying AI to engineering and
like how you build companies,
everything's changing and
that's, I think that's really
fun.
Yeah, I think we're living in
interesting times where it's
hard to predict what things will
be like in 10 years time.
It's hard to.
Yes.
Is it going to really be
different or is it just going to
stay the same?
I have a feeling it will
genuinely be different.
I, I just feel like I I use
these tools enough and I'm sure
you're the same, that I think
it's more.
It's more than hype and anybody
just says that.
I think they need to use these
tools themselves to see the
potential.
I mean, one of the key things,
so we work with customers like
we really encourage all the
executives CEO down, right.
I mean with a lot of like
CTOs, CIOs, but also CEO right,
very important that they lead by
example like embrace these
tools, right?
If you want your word, if you
believe in this, right.
But yeah, like Silicon Valley
hype cycle is at its all time.
That's right.
Like it is just crazy times.
But you know, I I've seen these
waves before.
I you've seen them as well,
right?
Like I do think things do get
over hyped, but you know, people
said cloud was over hyped for a
long time and actually they were
totally wrong.
It was way under hyped, right?
Like go look at a Gartner report
from like 2010 about like cloud
computing, right?
They probably didn't even have a
quadrant, right?
Like it's just like, but I think
my intuition, like I think as
you said earlier, and it is hard
to forecast these things, right?
Especially like 10 years.
That was a long time.
But from first principles, if
you could pass the Turing test,
that changes a lot of things
because the way you sort of
interact and that so that
interacting with a human or an
AI is similar.
You can say 1's better than the
other, whatever.
But I think that changes, yeah,
how entire organization is
built, right?
Because like, like you said, you
can manage a bunch of agents
instead of people is also maybe
managing agents is easier than
managing people, right?
Like, you know, like, but it's
a, it's a new paradigm.
And then it's like, of course
things are going to be
overhyped.
So if you take AI surrogates as
an example, you see somebody
saying, Hey, you know, you could
do something 10,000 times
faster.
You know, there's a big.
Asterisk there that's sort of
hidden about like well, but
you'd be able to write training
data and like he gets a 99.9% accuracy, yes, but like
even more training data and then
you know, how does this work
your organization?
Well, then you need this and
that and so but that's what I
call example, like sort of over
hyping.
But then if you look at like the
real implications, right?
Like now all of a sudden you
take a bunch of tasks that
engineers were going to do.
And if you compress this, like,
as we were speaking earlier,
something from three days into
like an hour or less or like a
second, right?
It it's a, it's a sort of like
there's a lot of implications to
how the entire sort of ecosystem
changes.
I don't think you can challenge
that, right?
Like, so you can, you can sort
of take this one data point and
say, like, well, simulations are
not actually 1000 times faster
today versus like 3 years ago,
right?
But, you know, on the one hand,
I don't think you can blame the
marketers because like they're
just doing their job trying to
grab your attention.
It's hard to get somebody's
attention.
Yeah, the like, can something
actually be 1000 times faster,
like given the right conditions?
Yes, right.
And then and then it's like,
hey, if you implement this in
the right way, I think the
benefits are much more
interesting than 1000 times
faster simulations.
It's like now you have designers
who can get real time physics
responses.
Yeah, right.
They're pretty accurate.
I think you can take this
concept of like at a very high
level with AI. One sort of framework
that I think is important for
organizations to think about is
like these engineering
organizations are highly, highly
complex.
And one of the big challenges is
the people.
So at Boeing, right, you go in
for like a detailed design
review and they're like, oh, we
got to call up like this world
famous expert who's like 78
years old, right?
And they sort of come in and
they like pontificate and give
you advice on like whether this
is going to work or not.
But the intelligence of the
organization gets sort of lost
as the people leave the
organization.
And so like, the problem is if
you like lose the best people
for say, building an airplane,
if that knowledge was actually
just like in their heads and
like you can kind of see their
work, but like you don't really
kind of understand exactly how
they did that.
And then maybe there was like a
aerospace industry goes through
many cycles.
So there's like a time there's
like 10 years didn't hire
anybody.
So there was no like
apprenticeship training, right?
And so you, you've lost a lot of
the ability of the sort of IP of
like how to actually build great
airplanes can be solved with
AI. AI can kind of like sort of
again, aggregate a lot of this
detailed stuff, synthesize it.
It's not always going to be
perfect or always going to be
right, but it can do a much
better job in a much shorter
amount of time than any person
can really do right.
And so if you think of AI as
ability to do things like that,
it's pretty incredible.
And then like the, if you just
project forward to even like
forget about 10 years, like 6
months or like 12 months, right?
You know, I will say, like when
I saw ChatGPT the first time,
right?
I'm like, like, interesting toy,
But I didn't actually think at
that time, the first time I used
it so I could just get a change.
I think it was cool that I could
give certain answers, but I
didn't think it was going to
change my like day-to-day
workflow.
And like today, I don't think an
hour goes by, but I'm not like
prompting AI models and and
running stuff in the background
and all kinds of stuff going on,
right?
And so like, that is a new way
of working.
And if you talk to new founders
that are building new companies,
right, that's how they're doing
it.
And they're just like I was,
there's like the the Claude Code
founder, right?
It's kind of showcasing how he's
like does software development.
He's got like all these
different agents and all this
stuff, right?
And you know, this Claude Code
thing was just a hack day
project for him like a year ago.
And now it's like at I think 400
million run rate, right?
So like this is no joke, right?
And that's, I think that same
sort of shift is going to happen
in for engineers and scientists,
right?
Like the exact timing of these
things is always really hard to
predict, but same thing with
like cloud HPC, right?
Like I think the the it's easy
to be right about sort of the
secular trends, if you will, at
least from my perspective,
right, where it's like you're
going to get more processor
fragmentation, like Moore's law
is going to kind of slow down
and like got to go to
specialized processors and all
this stuff, right?
If you want to just get more
advanced computing, just all
these things are going to
happen.
It's very hard to say like at
what exact point in time it's
good this like big shift or
whatever and sort of the Overton
window of what's acceptable to
people will shift, right.
But you could be right about the
trends, right?
And so same thing with AI, I think
you can kind of see where this
is going.
And I think then the timing is
really hard.
I would say all the AI
predictions I would have made in
the last 12 months would have
been like, if they were about
something that happened in the
last 12 months, they would have,
I would have predicted them over
longer time horizons than they
actually happened over, right?
Like, and so if everything is
just happening much faster, I
almost don't even trust my own
intuition and forecasting too
much, right?
And so like what?
Well, what can you do to prepare
for that is like, I think you
got to really lean in to like
that future.
And so like, even if right now,
like an example is like you can
do CAD and CAE modeling through
natural language prompting
through MCP, right?
So like this concept of model
context protocol, think of it
like an API, right?
It's sort of like connect like a
piece of software with like
your, your favorite AI tooling
and it can interact.
So we have a Rescale MCP.
You can interact with it.
You can spin up jobs and do all
the all the things you'd want to
do in the user interface, But
you can now do it through an
LLM.
But then you can connect to LLM
to like a CAD tool, right.
And you say, hey, like, you
know, change the angle of this
like windshield.
You're the author of the DrivAerML data set.
Like create all these models.
Like you probably did it
manually.
And so like now you just yeah,
so now you just say, hey, you
know, like building this design
space here's like the
parameters, right, to generate
all the CAD.
It can do that today.
Now your CAD designer is going
to say, Oh yeah, it can do that.
But look, look at the
discontinuity over there.
Like because of this thing and
like whatever.
Like it's not good enough yet to
like 100% replace it.
But the whole point is like not
to 100% replace.
The point is now you can generate
CAD like nobody's business,
right?
Like it's as easy as a prompt
that is just going to get way
better, right?
Like, so if, if we're talking
about like, is this going to be
good enough to do the like
aerospace level carbon fiber
layup design work?
Absolutely at some point, right?
Is that in like 1 month or is
that in 12 months?
Or is that in two years?
I don't know, but it's getting
really, really good, right?
And so those curves are really
fast and the adoption curves of
the of the technology are
usually pretty slow in
enterprise, right?
So like just because it's
possible doesn't mean people
adopt it, But you know, these
industry pressures are real,
right?
Like I, I do think like if you
can just kind of do innovation a
lot faster in automotive, in
aerospace, in like semiconductor
and life sciences, they're all
very big R&D spenders, right.
So if you just get a lot more
leverage out of that investment,
you know, that's a, that's a
huge leverage for society, I
think.
So maybe a final question, more
of a forward-looking question or
advice question.
Given all that we've said, if
you are a young founder, OK,
you're coming out of the first
job or a PhD and you, you know,
you think, what problem can I
try and tackle without giving
away anything that you you're
working on so you can't get too
good around.
So I guess what would be like
the biggest unsolved challenge
that you think the next startup
should try to tackle?
Yeah, there's a lot of big
challenges out there.
I think this is going to sound a
little bit self-serving, but if
you're amazing, you can always
come work at Rescale.
My e-mail is joris@rescale.com.
But I think this look, all the
things we've discussed, so
they're all happening right now,
right?
And so like I say, so where's
like the sort of next challenge
lie?
I do think it's in this kind of
like very buzzwordy word like
digital twin.
But like there is this, you
know, this concept of digital
twin, right, which is the the
equivalent of like what's
happening in the real world in a
digital form.
That concept is super important.
And this sort of sim-to-real
gap, like real being reality,
right?
And the sim being the kind of
the simulation of that reality,
the more you can close that gap,
the more powerful products you
can build, right?
So like a good example I think
is I don't know if you've been
to San Francisco taking like a
Waymo.
Oh yeah, that freaks me out.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, Yeah, I, I think Waymo is
like the coolest thing now.
Why is Waymo so impressive?
I remember there were self
driving vehicles in San
Francisco about roughly 10 years
before.
Like Waymo kind of really went
live for like the sort of
private data slash real people,
right, consumers that last mile
of like whether it's regulatory
or like getting the software to
the right level, etcetera.
Took a long time, the way longer
than I expected.
At that time I would have said
like, oh, in a year, if they're
testing it right now, like in a
year, this is going to be ready,
right?
And you sort of know all the
technology already works.
Like you already know, self
driving kind of works.
There's obviously a lot of
safety and things like that.
But that I think that's a great
example of like Waymo is able to
simulate, right, what's
happening in the real world very
effectively.
Like locally on the edge uses
enormous amount of AI, right?
Enormous amount of training
data, right?
And it, it sort of solves this
transportation problem in a way
that's like awesome, right?
Like it's, you know, I and I
think that's a great example of
like what the future looks like.
Then then you have to ask
yourself like, OK, well, what
are the next set of problems?
Well, robots is an obvious one,
right?
So like if you can solve this
sort of simulation problem for
robots, I don't know if you've
watched these robots like
folding laundry, but it's like.
I kind of wait.
You know, it's it's yeah, but
it's it's not pretty when you
watch them walk or fold laundry
or some of these robot Olympics
that are going on.
We got a ways to go that said,
like, we all understand physics,
right?
So like, this is actually a
solved problem.
Like we we know how robots
should operate in a sort of real
world, right?
And I think NVIDIA's done amazing
work in,
like, sort of,
developing the software and SDKs
for like the virtual world for
this, right?
And so you can sort of train
these models in a virtual way,
but ultimately you want to kind
of get that sim-to-real,
right?
Like somebody's going to build
all these robots.
These robots are going to go do
all the things you don't want to
do at home.
And that's solving those types
of problems.
If you're like sort of have a
simulation background, right, is
I think that's the next
frontier, right?
And you already have this
example of Waymo, right?
And to me, like, I think if you
really think closing the sim-to-
real gap is possible for
anything you're passionate
about, you can do for airplanes,
you can do for robots, you can
do for Earth, right?
Like there's this Earth model
again.
NVIDIA has done an amazing job
developing this weather
simulation, you know,
horrendously difficult problem,
but worth solving, right?
Like if you solve weather
prediction, you know, a little
bit better or even like say 10X
better saves a lot of lives,
right?
It makes it makes a big
difference, right?
And yeah, I think those are
meaningful missions.
You know, talk a little bit
about starting a company.
You join a company, Do you, do
you stay in academia?
It's I think you have to really
think for yourself what what are
you motivated by, right?
Like, like, what do you really
want to do, right?
I personally would encourage
people to generally like veer
towards where they can make the
biggest impact and going to
learn the most right.
And so can be a start up, can be
a big company, could be many
different sort of platforms can
be in university.
But I I do think what's what we
need more of is like the people
to really have the courage to
kind of, I think, solve the
problems that are really on the
edge, but nobody solved before.
The problem with academia in my
view is like I spent a lot of
time in school, right?
A lot too many degrees.
And it's sort of like, I think
the challenge with school is
that you start competing on a
dimension that's that's a little
bit removed from like the
practical reality and you start
competing.
I'm like, you know, can we solve
this equation more efficiently,
whether or not Boeing like uses
this and adopts this or anybody
else does, as long as this other
really smart person thinks it's
smart, right?
And I get a lot of references,
like I win the game, so to
speak, right?
But, you know, like it's, I
think it's like, I think it's
Kissinger quote, which is like
the battles in academia are so
fierce because the stakes are so
small.
So, you know, I I think that's a
yeah, it's, it's, it's
unfortunate because you see a
lot of really great talent,
right?
And, you know, I was part of
this as well myself, right?
You know, Peter Thiel has a good
view on this as well.
I think where it's like it's
really elite students who are
super smart and they keep
climbing this sort of academic ladder.
Why?
Because these are like the
badges you want to collect.
I went to Stanford, I went to
Harvard.
I get to this and that right
have all the sort of
certifications, but that's sort
of like the status game and like
signaling to other people,
right?
I think.
And the problem is, you know,
he, what he talks about is that
like the sort of the in that
process, the sort of dreams get
stomped out of you, right?
And that's his view.
I think that's, that's, that's
pretty correct.
I also think there's a
specialization that happens
because like, OK, you want to be
best in the world at something,
you know, narrow, narrow,
narrow, narrow, right?
But great innovation actually
often happens by, you know,
taking concepts from 1 field,
applying it in another, right?
Like, like it's actually like
the DeepMind folks that sort of
like MeshGraphNets, etcetera.
Like that's why we have AI
surrogates and they're not all like
physics experts, right?
Like, in fact, you often need
somebody from a domain who's
like naive enough to be like,
hey, let's just try this thing.
And so I do think you want
people to follow like a mission
and sort of a like, like the
where they're passionate about,
right?
It's like, if you're your 20s,
like, like you probably have
enough life experience to kind
of know what, what you like.
And there's so much more
possible than people think they
are capable of themselves,
right?
Like I personally would have
never thought when I was like an
engineer, simulation engineer
working at Boeing doing my
little thing, right, that I
could kind of break out, start
your own company, get these like
like maybe they sit across the
table from like some of the
smartest people in Silicon
Valley and together kind of like
it like build an amazing
company, right?
And I think it takes you of
course need the ambition, but
most of all you need the courage
and the the willingness to kind
of persevere, right?
Many people give up, like, I
don't know if you see this, but
like, you know, there's a lot of
people who apply to jobs at
Rescale and I see a lot of
resumes and like you see a lot
of this, like, hey, 1 1/2 years
here, 1 1/2 years there,
etcetera.
Right?
I, I think you got to kind of
find that right, problem that
you're really passionate about
and then like really pursue that
with, with all the energy you
have.
There's a good essay written by
Paul Graham called, it's called
great work or something like
that.
It's like how to do great work.
It's kind of a long essay, so it
might take a while to read, but
one of the things he talks about
is like, you know, you want to
be on the edges, like sort of
the he thinks of like knowledge
as this sort of like tree and
these like fractals basically.
And you're sort of want to be on
the edge, right?
And then you want to kind of see
where the gaps are.
And often I, I think I'm not
sure if he talks about an essay,
but in my view, it's like if you
take kind of the lessons from a
certain field applying in
another.
That's where I've seen like
amazing breakthroughs like that
Rescale and like also beyond
like in places like Boeing and
other places.
And that requires like the
willingness to kind of learn
these different things, right?
And, and sort of apply that
curiosity in different ways.
So, you know, for somebody who
is just graduating with their,
you know, master's or PhD or
something like I would look to
the in short, I would go
somewhere where I think you're
going to learn the most or make
the biggest impact.
What is hard is that there's a
lot of like societal things that
will pressure you to do other
things, right, Like maybe go
work for the company that has
the brand that your parents will
be proud of you for, right?
Like it's a natural thing,
right?
Like maybe go, you know, like,
for example, if you just start a
company, it's like, well, like
now you're unemployed is a
different view of the same
thing, right?
Like, so I think that some of
these things are hard, but but
you know, I do think people
could take much more risks than
they usually think they can,
right?
And the challenge is a little
bit as if you find that out late
in life, there are less
opportunities.
Like we, we all have just time,
right?
And, and that's the sort of the,
the great equalizer.
You know, people spend a lot of
time doing work.
I certainly do.
I think it's like the that time
that you spent, it should be
something really meaningful to
you.
I can't just be a mean student,
right?
Like I love spending time with
my kids and family and those
things too, right?
But like, if you're a motivated
individual, you're probably
going to spend a lot of time
working, right?
And so that whatever that work
is, it should be, you know, I
wouldn't compromise that too
much for, say, like a better
salary.
You're like a mission you're not
so excited about, right?
A lot of big tech companies that
have, you know, some missions
are certainly more interesting
than others, right?
And I think applying yourself to
kind of make an impact, you
know, move society forward is
super important.
Yeah, wise words and thank you
so much for this.
I love this conversation and I
think what we need to do is
schedule in like a few years
time and see how close we were,
whether we're all using AI
engineers or whether we were
wrong.
I'm sure something completely
different will have come around
that neither of us predicted, but
it'd be a good thing to see.
So with with that, thank you
Joris, really, really
appreciated your time.
Thank you, Neil.
Thanks for the opportunity.
And yeah, let's let's put it on
the calendar and pass it back
up.
Sounds good.
All right.
Cheers.
Thank you.
See you.